The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
HONG LIU: So let
me first remind you
what we did at the
end of last lecture.
Say, suppose you can
see the string moving
in some spacetime M. So it's
the following metric, given
by g mu nu and the coordinate,
which I've denoted by X nu.
So nu typically will go from,
say, mu nu, go from 0, 1 to D
minus 1.
And capital D will be
the [? number of ?]
spacetime dimension.
And then the worldsheets will
be characterized by this X mu
as a function of worldsheet
coordinate sigma tau.
Then this describe
the [? mapping ?]
of a two-dimensional surface
embedded in the full spacetime.
And then we also
use the notation
of X mu equal to
sigma a, and sigma a
will be sigma 0, sigma 1, and
equal to tau and sigma, OK?
And then the simplest
action, which
have a clear geometric
meaning, is essentially
just the action that is given
by the area of the surface.
Given by the area
of the surface.
And this delta h is
the induced metric.
So if you have embedding
in this spacetime,
then this embedding will
induce a longitudinal metric
on the worldsheets.
So this h is the induced
metric on the worldsheet.
And then if you take
the determinant of it,
then it essentially
gives you the area.
[? Adamant ?] on
the worldsheets.
But we also showed
that classically, this
is action is equivalent
to this action.
You can rewrite it by
introducing something
like a Lagrangian
multiplier like gamma ab.
And then by eliminate gamma
ab, then you cover this.
OK?
And the equation of motion
for the gamma ab-- yeah,
if you solve the equation
for gamma ab, the thing
you will get something
like this, lambda hab.
And lambda is
arbitrary constant.
Arbitrary function.
Yeah, say if you solve
the equation of motion
for gamma ab, and then
that's what you get.
So for this final
form, so this is
the action we will
use to quantize it,
is because this action have
a nice polynomial form.
Have a nice polynomial form.
Not like this action,
which is a square root.
It's always awkward.
And so this have a
nice polynomial form.
And then when you
quantize the action,
say if you do path
integral quantization,
then you need to integrate
both dynamic variables.
So exponential i
Sp gamma on X. OK.
So both are dynamic variables.
When you quantize, you
have to do path integral
over all of them.
And so let me just
say a little bit more
about the geometric, which
we mentioned at the end
in last lecture, the geometric
meaning of this action.
So if you just look
at this action itself,
this just like a scalar field
in a two-dimensional curved
spacetime.
And this two-dimensional
curved spacetime
have a longitudinal metric,
which is given by gamma.
And the scalar field
is just this X, OK?
So this gamma can be considered
as some kind of intrinsic.
And we can see that
as an intrinsic metric
on the worldsheet.
And then this X still
describes this embedding
of this worldsheet in spacetime.
But X, from the point of
view of this two-dimensional
worldsheet, it just behave
like a scalar field.
It just behave like
a scalar field.
So when we quantize
this action, so
when we do the path
integral, if you just
do the path integral
over DX, then
this is just like a standard
two-dimensional quantum field
theory, OK?
Just like a standard
two-dimensional quantum field
theory.
But what's unusual
here, when you quantize
a string, because the gamma
is also a dynamic variable,
you also have to
integrate over gamma.
And this make it
more nontrivial,
and then this is no longer
just like quantizing the scalar
fields.
And because you are integrating
over all possible intrinsic
metrics on the worldsheet.
So this is like
quantizing 2D gravity.
When you integrate over
all possible metric,
then this is like
quantizing gravity.
But this is only the
gravity on the worldsheet,
coupled to D scalar fields.
OK?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So in what
sense is it 2D gravity?
Because the metric is
like a D by D object.
HONG LIU: No, no.
Gamma is a
two-dimensional metric.
It's intrinsic metric
on the worldsheet.
Yeah, so it's two by two.
[? ab's ?] only goes two by two.
ab is only going from 0 to 1.
Yeah, so ab only runs over
the worldsheet at 0 to 1.
Yeah.
So once you write
that form, then
you introduce an intrinsic
metric on the worldsheet.
They introduce an
intrinsic curved spacetime
on the worldsheet.
And when you integrate
over all possible metrics,
then that's corresponding
to take into account
the fluctuations in the metric,
from this two-dimensional point
of view.
So that's why we say this is
like quantizing 2D gravity.
By gravity we just
mean the spacetime.
OK, is this clear?
So now we see the
question of quantizing
the string theory,
essentially [INAUDIBLE]
to quantize this two-dimensional
gravity on worldsheets
coupled to these scalar fields.
And these scalar fields
describe the embedding
of your worldsheet.
OK?
So we will consider
a simple example.
We will consider
the example which
M is just Minkowski spacetime.
Three-dimensional
Minkowski spacetime, OK?
So in this case, g mu nu
[? come ?] [? equal ?] to eta
[INAUDIBLE] nu.
And then this Polyakov action
can also be simplified.
So this SP now just
become 1 over [? 4 ?]
alpha prime, d square sigma,
gamma ab, partial a X mu,
partial b X mu.
So now when I write
this X mu, X mu
should be understood
that they are
contracted by the
standard Minkowski metric.
So now, this is really,
if you just look at the X,
this is like free
scalar field series,
because of the dependence
on x, purely quadratic.
So this is like a free scalar
field in curved spacetime,
in curved worldsheet,
2D worldsheet.
So this still slightly unusual
thing about this scalar field
theory, from our standard one.
Actually, I might be missing
a minus sign somewhere.
I might be missing
overall minus sign.
I think I'm missing
Just let me put it here.
overall minus signs.
For our current purpose,
it does not matter.
But I think for the
later purpose we need it.
Because if you can see
the standard field theory
using this minus [? 1 ?] metric,
then I need the minus sign.
OK?
So this is just like a
free scalar field theory
in this 2D curved spacetime.
But the slightly [? thing ?]
unusual about this one,
so there are two unusual things.
One is that we also
need to integrate gamma.
But there's a lot
of unusual things,
even from the perspective
of scalar field theory.
And so if you look at
the 0-th component of X,
because eta 0,0-- we are using
the eta equal to minus 1, 1.
Because eta 0,0 is minus 1.
So the 0-th component of X, we
have a opposite kinetic term
to the other component, OK?
So you might have learned in
your quantum field theory class
that actually you cannot change
the sign of your kinetic term.
Otherwise you get instability,
because then your Hamiltonian
will be unbounded
from below, et cetera.
So this action, so our story
here have two unusual features.
One, you have to
integrate over gamma.
And the second is
that [? the 1 over ?]
the scalar field have
the wrong kinetic term.
OK.
The sign with kinetic
term is wrong.
And we will see that these
two features actually
solve for each other.
And this is actually
a consistent theory.
So this is actually consistency.
Any questions at this point?
OK, so before you do any
theory, what you should do?
So before you work
on any theory,
what should you do first?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
HONG LIU: No, no,
that's too far away.
Just the first
thing you should do.
After you write down the action
[? Lagrange, ?] what should do?
AUDIENCE: Solve the
equation of motion.
HONG LIU: That's
still too far away.
AUDIENCE: Check units.
HONG LIU: That's something
what you should do.
Yeah, but that is
done in kindergarten,
so it's not included here.
AUDIENCE: Constants of motion.
HONG LIU: That's close.
What is responsible
for constant of motion?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: Symmetry.
HONG LIU: Yeah, that's
right, symmetry.
You first have to
analyze the symmetries.
OK, so that's what we will do.
OK, let me call
this equation three,
just continue from my
notation of last week.
Yeah.
So first we should analyze
the symmetry of this action.
So first, so this is a mapping
to a Minkowski spacetime.
The Minkowski
[? spacetime ?] itself
have a Poincare symmetry.
And that Poincare symmetry
will be reflected here.
First we have the
Poincare symmetry of X mu.
In other words-- and this
action is invariant--
if you take X mu to go
to X mu plus a constant.
OK, so a mu is a constant.
So it's obvious this is
invariant because everything
on [? X ?] we said derivative.
So if we shift by X
mu with a constant,
then I'll call that a symmetry.
And also, this is invariant
under Lorentz symmetry.
OK.
So lambda is the constant
Lorentz transformation.
OK?
So this is also self-evident,
because of this contraction,
if you make a constant
Lorentzian transformation,
you don't see the derivatives.
And then this is contracted
as Lorentz scalar,
then this is invariant.
OK?
So this is the first
set of symmetry.
The second set of symmetry
essentially by construction,
because we are writing
this as a scalar
field in the curved spacetime.
Then this is invariant in the
two-dimensional coordinate
transformation.
And in other words,
this is invariant
on the reparameterization
of the worldsheet.
OK.
So this is essentially
a less [? desirable ?]
condition, which should
satisfy by any string action,
because as we said
before, sigma tau,
you just parameterize
your worldsheet.
And you actually
should not depend on
how you parameterize it,
and that parameterization
should be arbitrary.
You should be able to change
your parameterization.
Because if you think about
the surface in spacetime,
no matter, you can say
parameterization cause
[INAUDIBLE] agreed
on the surface.
Whether you do it this way, or
you do it in some other way,
if you're not changing the
surface, the property of the
surface itself.
So that means the
action itself should not
be invariant on the
reparameterization
of your worldsheet.
And the parameterization
of the worldsheet
translates into just arbitrary
coordinate transformations.
So sigma and tau
should be able to, say,
if you make arbitrary
coordinate transformation,
and the action
should be invariant.
OK.
And this is by construction.
And this is action by
construction in [? Lorentz. ?]
And this number goes to action.
And Polyakov action we
obtained by rewriting
this number called action.
It's also about construction.
Because its [? manner fits ?]
because this
is in [INAUDIBLE] in the
curved space actions for scalar
fields.
So this automatically
invariant under
the coordinate transformation.
And under this coordinate
transformation,
this X mu just transformed
[? my ?] scalar field.
So the scalar field transforms.
Say as the following
is going to X mu prime.
And X mu prime,
we've evaluated here
that the new coordinate
tau prime and sigma prime
should be the same as
your original X evaluated
at the original location.
So this is essentially the
definition of a scalar field.
You see that when you make
a coordinate transformation,
if you follow the point, the
value of X does not change.
Because when you go
to the new location,
the X prime evaluated
at new location
should be the same as
your original value.
OK.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So basically we
have a few more [INAUDIBLE]
variants in real space,
and the worldsheet.
That's like--
HONG LIU: No, no, this is not if
your [? morphism ?] invariant.
No, this is not [? different ?]
[? morphism ?] invariant.
AUDIENCE: What about in
a special case, though?
HONG LIU: No, this is not
[? different ?] [? morphism. ?]
No, this is not different
[? morphism. ?] This is global
symmetry.
AUDIENCE: Oh, yeah, OK.
AUDIENCE: And also, did we ever
consider curved real space?
HONG LIU: Yeah, you can
consider-- well, curved space.
But right now we are at the high
school level of string theory
class, and if you
go to curved space,
there should be college in
that level of string theory.
It's beyond what we
are doing right now.
AUDIENCE: That's
[INAUDIBLE] curve of space,
we don't have Poincare.
Will we have Poincare?
HONG LIU: Yeah, then you
don't have Poincare symmetry.
So this is specific
to this action.
But this is [INAUDIBLE] general.
So, of course, under this
coordinate transformation,
this gamma ab should
transform as a tensor,
as in standard [? in GR. ?]
This evaluated gamma prime you
evaluate at a new point, should
be [? related ?] as a tensor.
OK.
So you can check yourself.
This essentially
by constructing,
but you can check yourself
that the action is indeed
invariant under those
transformations.
OK?
AUDIENCE: Is there also gauge
symmetry for this, [INAUDIBLE]
add a [? phase ?] to X and
derivative with a it cancels.
HONG LIU: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: Is there
[? any gauge's ?] theory in--
HONG LIU: Gauge in what?
Gauge in which one?
AUDIENCE: X, like
in equation three,
[INAUDIBLE] either global
[? phase ?] to X and derivative
with a and--
HONG LIU: No, no, no.
No, X is real here.
This is our full action.
AUDIENCE: I see.
OK.
HONG LIU: Yeah, these
are full action.
X are real.
So this is invariant on that.
We will not show this
is [? invariant. ?]
This just essentially
by construction.
You should check it yourself,
if you are not convinced.
So the third symmetry is called
a Weyl scaling of gamma ab.
So the [INAUDIBLE] are
slightly surprising.
So under this symmetry,
X mu does not change.
But the metric we multiply
it by overall prefactor.
And this omega is
arbitrary for any function.
OK.
So this is a very important
symmetry, so let's check that.
So when you multiply the gamma
by our overall prefactor,
when you go to gamma
ab, then that's
giving you the same prefactor,
but with a minus sign here.
And now, in the
determinant for gamma,
then that give you
the square of these.
And then take the square root,
then give you a positive power.
Then they cancel.
Is it clear?
So the [INAUDIBLE] power here
cancels with the positive power
here.
OK?
So this thing is invariant.
On [INAUDIBLE] symmetry.
So the way to see that--
another way to understand
that somehow this
action-- so the same thing
with this action.
This is not specific
to we are working
with Minkowski spacetime.
The same feature here only
depend on these two, OK?
So the same thing happens here.
So you can also
see a feature why--
and you can also get a feeling
why this is such symmetry,
just by looking at the relation
between the Nambu-Goto action
with this action.
So in this Nambu-Goto
action, there's no gamma.
OK, so in some
sense you can see.
You can say this
is automatically
invariant under this
kind of symmetry,
because there's no gamma.
And now we see that
the equivalence--
we write down equation
of motion to go
from here to Nambu-Goto action.
The equivalence
between them, they
can be related by
arbitrary function lambda.
And really by aperture
function lambda,
yeah, this is another
way to see this symmetry.
OK?
It's another way to
see this symmetry.
So in some sense, you can say
that this symmetry is also
required for the equivalence
to the Nambu-Goto action, OK?
So we can actually use-- we
can also turn things around.
We can also use as a
symmetry principle.
OK.
I see major points
that we can ask.
Suppose we have action.
Suppose we require an action
to satisfy the a, b, c,
to be invariant under a, b, c.
What is the most general action?
OK?
And then, you can essentially
uniquely determine the three.
OK.
We use actually
symmetry principles
to uniquely-- actually, it's
almost uniquely determined.
OK, so I will explain
this "almost."
So now I use this clear.
Is the logic clear?
So we do two ways.
We first start with Nambu-Goto
and then we go to this action.
But then we observe this
action having the symmetries.
And now we ask ourselves, what
is the most general action
besides symmetries?
OK.
And that then leads us back
to this term, to this action.
Except there's one
more term you can add.
OK.
There's one other
term you can add.
So that's why this is almost.
So I will just
immediately write it down.
This is called an Euler action.
So this action actually
have a long history.
So this is called Euler action.
So this can be
written as following.
And this lambda is
just a constant,
some arbitrary constant.
And R is the Ricci
scalar for gamma ab.
OK, gamma ab is symmetric.
It's a two-dimensional metric.
We will construct the
corresponding Ricci scalar.
So you can clearly
check this action-- so
let me call this equation four.
So you can check easily that a
four is invariant under a plus
b under a.
Because this does not
depend on X. OK, of course,
this is invariant under a.
And this is invariant
under b, because this
is a covariant action,
so this invariant on b.
To see this is invariant
under c requires
a little bit of effort.
Okay, requires a
little bit of effort.
But if I write down the formula,
then it will become clear.
So under c, if you make
such a transformation,
say under gamma prime equal to
[? exponent ?] 2 omega gamma.
[? 2w ?] gamma.
And then you find that minus
gamma prime and R prime-- R
prime means the Ricci
scalar for the gamma prime--
is equal to square root
minus gamma, R minus 2.
The 2-- yeah, this is a formula
which you can check yourself.
Maybe just directly write down.
And then you see you
get one more term,
but this term is a
total derivative.
OK, so this term is
a total derivative.
And if we impose the
right boundary conditions,
or if you can see the
compact worldsheets,
then this term will
automatically vanishes,
and then this is invariant.
OK?
So we have shown this is
invariant under everything, a
to c.
So essentially, that's it.
So these two terms are
only-- three and four
are the only terms are
invariant under a to c, OK?
There's no other terms.
So total action.
Then.
And then this is
our total action.
So actually some of you who
knows two-dimensional gravity.
AUDIENCE: Is there a minus sign?
HONG LIU: Yeah.
Maybe let me put
the minus sign here.
Good.
So some of you who know
the two-dimensional gravity
will immediately point
out, you actually
don't need to add this term.
Because this is actually
a total derivative.
So this is a property of--
I only make a claim here.
So this thing is a
total derivative.
So you can check yourself.
Go back, go to your
favorite GR book,
go to your favorite GR
book, and we'll call it
the scalar, Ricci scalar in 2D.
And then you find actually
the square root of gamma times
i is actually a
total derivative.
So it will not affect the
equation motion, et cetera.
But it is important.
Otherwise I would not
have talked about it.
Because when you go to the
Euclidean signature, that's
the standard way we
evaluate the path integral.
So when you go to
Euclidean signature,
this is only-- saying that this
is a total derivative is only
a local description.
It's actually a
local description.
In fact, this is actually
a topological term.
So locally, you can write
it as a total derivative.
But if you put on the
topological [? nontrivial ?]
manifold, then you
cannot do it globally.
And so, in fact, in the
Euclidean signature,
it's a-- actually I don't know
whether this is due to Euler.
This Euler action is actually
equal to lambda times chi.
And the chi is
equal to [? pi-- ?]
yeah, which is
defined to be-- so now
it's R. It's actually
2 minus 2h, OK?
And the h is the
genus of the surface.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
HONG LIU: No, this
is only in 2D.
AUDIENCE: This is
only true in 2D.
HONG LIU: Yeah, in 2D.
So in 2D, this-- even though
this is locally a total
derivative, but it's
not the global total--
But you cannot write a
total derivative globally.
And so we integrated over
a nontrivial manifold.
But manifold with a nontrivial
topology-- actually,
this is [INAUDIBLE].
It actually gives you
this Euler number.
So example, if you
integrated on a sphere,
then you find that
this number is 2,
because [? when ?] h equal to 0.
And if you evaluate
it on the torus,
then you find that
this is 0, et cetera.
OK.
So one second.
So in the Euclidean
path integral,
so Euclidean path
integral, this S minus--
so this exponential
S Euler term--
just give you exponential
[? s ?] lambda chi, OK?
So now you may ring a bell,
because this is precisely
the [INAUDIBLE] term I
added before when I say,
when we sum over
different genus.
You have the freedom to add
[? mechanical ?] potential,
lambda times the Euler number.
And actually this is
dictated by the symmetry.
And if you include the
most general terms are
consistent with
those symmetries,
then you are required to
include this Euler term.
And then you'll have
automatically weight,
that you would
automatically have a weight
for different genus, OK?
But for this theory, the
lambda is actually constant.
So the choice of lambda
is still arbitrary,
but this does give you
a nontrivial weight.
So this is weight--
different genus.
Yeah.
Any questions about this, yes?
AUDIENCE: So if you have
[? a nontrivial ?] topology,
wouldn't the boundary term
from the symmetry also
be nontrivial?
So wouldn't the symmetry break?
HONG LIU: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: If you have a
nontrivial topology, what
is the total derivative
boundary term, total derivative
of the symmetry
transformation also?
HONG LIU: No.
No, they are different
kind of-- no,
there's no global issue here.
This is just a
ordinary function.
You have to write down
this explicit to know it.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So the claim was that
[? efficient ?] work, no matter
what value [INAUDIBLE] input.
So this is why you were able to
put in that factor at the sum.
We could make lambda equal 0,
in which case, we don't have it.
HONG LIU: Yeah.
Lambda is not
dictated by symmetry,
so lambda is just a
free parameter here.
But in principle, if I
determine it exists, yeah.
Just lambda equal to
0 is a special case.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
HONG LIU: Yeah, in
the Minkowski case
it's a little bit tricky
to talk about topology,
[? et cetera. ?] So
that's why we always,
when we do the path
integral, we always
go to Euclidean signature.
And for example, later
when we quantized
the action, which we work
with at Lorentzian signature.
And we only care, say when we
solve the equation of motion,
but we only care about
the local structure.
Then we can just
ignore this term
because this does not contribute
[? to ?] local structure.
Good.
So to summarize, from the
two-dimensional-- so again,
we can signal this as
a two-dimensional field
theory coupled to in
the curved spacetime.
From that two-dimensional
perspective,
this is a global symmetry.
OK, so a is a global symmetry.
Because the symmetry
does not depend
on the sigma and the gamma,
and the sigma and tau.
So this should leave to conserve
charge, conserve current,
conserve charge and
conserve current.
OK?
So we're going to see
later this indeed plays
a very important
role in physics.
And the b and the c are what
we call the gauge symmetries,
or local symmetries, because
they depend on sigma and tau.
They have [? arbitrary ?]
dependence on sigma and tau.
There and here can also
depend on sigma and tau.
So this is what we call
the gauge symmetries.
So for those of you who have
started Quantum Field Theory II
or even Quantum Field Theory
I, for those of you who have
quantized [? QED, ?] you know
that the gauge symmetries are
not [? general ?] symmetries.
They just tells you they are
redundant degrees of freedom.
OK?
And they just redundantly
[? with the ?] freedom.
And then when you
quantize the theory,
then you need to rid of those
redundant degrees of freedom
first.
Because otherwise you will
have a consistency problem.
And the process of getting
rid of redundancy problems--
those redundancies are
called gauge fixing.
OK, so that's what we'll
get to a little bit later.
So in principle,
you can just proceed
to do the path integral
quantization as we did before.
And the path
integral quantization
is conceptually simple
and geometrically elegant.
But it does not give you,
say, string theory spectrum.
And because it's a path
integral, it's [INAUDIBLE].
If you really want to find what
are the spectrums of the string
theory, you actually have
to do the standard canonical
quantization.
So that's what we are
going to do next, OK?
Now we are going to quantize
the string in the canonical way.
There are many ways of doing it.
I will use the simplest
way, so [INAUDIBLE]
the simplest way, also
conceptually simplest way.
It's called the
light-cone quantization.
And the meaning of this
word will be clear.
So the basic picture will
emerge from this quantization
is that each oscillation
mode-- so if you have a string,
then you can oscillate, right?
Because that's what
the string does.
It can oscillate.
So each oscillation
mode, so the bottom line
is that we will show that each
oscillation mode of the string
gives rise to a
spacetime particle.
OK.
From the string
point of view, it
looks like some kind of
oscillation of string.
But from the spacetime
point of view,
it's like a spacetime particle.
In particular, if you
have a closed string,
then that will give
rise, say, graviton.
Say one particular mode will
give you graviton and then
many other particles.
Actually, we have an infinite
number of particles from string
because there's infinite
number of vibration
modes with a string.
And if you have an open string,
say the string which does not
close, and then
actually then you
find the gauge field-- a rise
in one of the vibration modes.
Say this can either be
photon or gluon, et cetera.
OK.
Yeah, so this is the
thing we like to show.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
HONG LIU: Oh, there are an
infinite number of particles.
So because the
string can oscillate,
just any string
oscillate in principle
in an infinite number of ways.
And if each oscillation
mode [? cause ?]
one into a particle, then you
can have an infinite number
of particles.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
HONG LIU: Oh yeah, oh yeah.
They're completely different
from gravitons and protons.
They're just completely
different particles.
AUDIENCE: So [INAUDIBLE]
particles [INAUDIBLE].
What other particles in the
same class with gravitons?
HONG LIU: Depend on
what you mean by class.
AUDIENCE: Well, can you
give a second [INAUDIBLE]?
In the same line as graviton,
[? what else can you do? ?]
HONG LIU: Oh, for example,
mass will spin two particles.
Mass will spin three particles.
AUDIENCE: Everything
will spin more than one?
HONG LIU: It can
also have a scalar
particle, [? massive ?]
scalar particles,
but they're all massive.
AUDIENCE: That'd be boson?
HONG LIU: They can be fermions.
In this theory they
can only be bosons.
But we can play tricks
to get fermions.
AUDIENCE: So does this
predict that-- so if you
were to have a string theory
model which would reproduce
the standard model,
this basically
says that at higher
and higher energies
that we expect to always
see new types of particles
or something?
HONG LIU: Yeah, that's right.
AUDIENCE: Interesting.
HONG LIU: But we will see.
You need to go to a
specific time-- we already
go to a specific
energy scale to see.
AUDIENCE: OK.
We can see how they're spaced.
HONG LIU: Yeah, yeah.
That's right.
Yeah, but that
space is determined
by some energy scale, and
that scale can be very high.
OK, so now we will
quantize this theory using
canonical quantization, OK?
So by canonical quantization--
so let me remind you,
this is the procedure.
So this is a
procedure we typically
explain, say, in the second day
of free quantum field theory.
And so we are doing
the same thing here.
So the quantization
procedure is the following.
The first step is you write
down equation of motion.
OK.
And in the case which you
have gauge symmetries,
then we fix the gauge symmetry.
And the third is
find the complete set
of classical solutions.
OK.
And the four is you
promote the classical field
on the worldsheet,
worldsheet field,
say the X or gamma
to quantum operators.
OK.
So the quantization
procedure is that you
promote them to
quantum operators,
which satisfy the
so-called canonical
[? computation ?] relation.
And the previous
equation of motion
then becomes operator
equations for those operators.
OK?
In particular, then
the classical solution
you find in three
becomes the solutions
to operator equations.
And in particular,
the parameters
we use to parameterize
your classical solutions--
so those become, say, the
creation and annihilation
operators.
Just as what we do in the free
field theory quantization.
And then the last step,
once you have the creation
and annihilation operators, then
you can just find the spectrum.
By acting the creation
and annihilation operators
on your vacuum, then you
can find the spectrum.
So find the spectrum.
So this is the
standard procedure.
Yeah, so this is almost exactly
the same as how we quantize
our free scalar field theory.
In Quantum Field Theory I,
the only tricky thing is now,
this is a system with
gauge symmetries.
That's the only
tricky thing here.
Any questions here?
So now let me just
again say some boundary
conditions we are going to use.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
HONG LIU: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: What are parameters
in classical solutions
permutations. [INAUDIBLE].
HONG LIU: What other--
AUDIENCE: Parameters
in classical solutions
in case of [INAUDIBLE].
HONG LIU: It's different modes
for your classical waves.
The amplitude for your
different classical waves.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
HONG LIU: Yeah, it
is like that, yeah.
For scalar field theory, yeah,
just for harmonic oscillator,
you can write a cosine.
a explains your i omega X
plus a star, [INAUDIBLE]
omega X. So a is the
parameter, and a and a star
become creation and
annihilation operator.
It's the same thing here.
So we will consider both
closed and open strings.
So suppose closed
and open strings.
So if you have a closed string,
then, just by convention
we always take sigma
to go from 0 to 2 pi.
So the closed string
means it's closed.
Then we take this
from to 0 to 2 pi.
That means whatever
function should
be a periodic function of 2 pi.
OK, should be a periodic
function of 2 pi,
because it's closed, OK?
So the same thing with gamma.
Same thing with gamma, OK?
But if you have open
string, by convention
we take sigma goes to 0 to pi.
So one end of the string
is at sigma equal to 0.
The other end is at
sigma equal to pi.
So for open strings, so
here is sigma equal to 0.
Here is sigma equal to pi.
So the sigma is
directly on the string.
So we need to-- for
open strings, then,
because you have
boundaries, then
we need to supply boundary
conditions at the end points.
Good.
So now with this
set-up, we can now just
follow that five steps, OK?
We can just follow that five
steps and quantize the string.
So do you want to have a break?
OK, let us start.
So we just follow these steps.
First let's write down
equation of motion.
OK, first we just do a
variation of gamma ab.
So gamma is the
worldsheet metric
from the point of view of
two-dimensional field theory.
The gamma is the
worldsheet metric.
When you do evaluation over
gamma, essentially what
you get is the stress tensor
for this worldsheet theory, OK?
So when you do the
[? evaluation over ?] gamma,
essentially, it's
just the statement
that the stress
tensor had to be 0.
OK.
And then you can work
this out explicitly.
And the stress tensor,
which I call Tab.
OK.
So I just
[? did the evaluation ?]
of that action with
respect to gamma ab.
This is what you get
You find this thing has
to be equal to 0.
And I just call this thing Tab.
And this Tab is essentially
the stress tensor of this.
If you [INAUDIBLE] the
scalar field theory,
so this Tab is essentially
the stress tensor
of this scalar field theory.
OK?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: If we add the
topological term and said,
there's a Ricci
scalar there, there
must be Einstein's
tensor equal to Tab.
HONG LIU: No, no, no.
Because there's a
total derivative term
in two dimensions--
never contribute to
equation of motion.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So but if we
calculated the Einstein tensor
for that R [INAUDIBLE] get 0.
HONG LIU: You will get 0, yeah.
AUDIENCE: Sorry, so
you just said that
from the equation of motion,
that gamma ab can get
gamma ab equals 1/2 lambda hab.
Is that it?
HONG LIU: Yeah.
It's the same thing.
But this is a very
good question.
Let me do that here.
Say if I write gamma ab
equal to 1/2 lambda hab,
I can write this
lambda explicitly.
Then I can modify this
by hab on both sides
and this means hab gamma
ab equal to lambda.
OK, that means lambda is
equal to gamma ab times hab.
And so this equation,
I can also write it
as gamma ab is equal to
1/2 hab gamma ab hab.
Oh, gamma cd.
Yeah, which you can show is
equivalent to that equation.
OK.
Or maybe I should do gamma ab.
No, if you do that
one, it doesn't matter.
I can do-- to be exactly
the same as that equation,
let me just do both sides.
I can track with gamma ab.
Let me see, maybe I can
[? track ?] both sides.
Let me think.
So that is [? HCD ?] so that is
h gamma ab, times that thing,
is equal to--
Yeah, you can-- just
take this equation.
You get this equation.
Then you can show that equation
is equivalent to this equation,
OK?
[INAUDIBLE] right now, they're
not reading the identical way,
but they can show
the equivalence.
So yeah, actually
that's your homework.
So now if you look at
equation of motion for X mu,
look at the equation
of motion for X
mu, then this is
just [INAUDIBLE]
your standard scalar field.
So this just give you-- OK,
and we call this equation six.
So these are all of
your equation of motion.
If you have open
string, then when
you do the evaluation
of X, you have
to do integration by parts.
Then in the standard
[? story, ?]
you have to have
a boundary term.
OK?
But you actually have to be
careful about that boundary
term.
For the open string, you
will get a boundary term,
which is given by delta mu
gamma sigma b partial b X
mu, evaluated at sigma equal to
0 and pi, should be equal to 0.
OK?
So this just come from where you
get this second-order equation,
you always have to
integration by parts
when you do the evaluation.
That just comes from
the boundary term
of that [? variation, ?]
evaluated
at the end point
of the string you
have in the sigma direction.
OK.
Is this clear?
Good.
Again, I will not go through
all the algebraic details.
You should check those
details yourself.
You should check them,
and if you find mistakes,
it's greatly encouraged.
Yeah, I will add to your points.
Yeah, if you find mistakes,
then I will add your points.
If you have found
enough mistakes,
then you may not need to
do the [? PSAT ?] anymore.
So this tells us we can actually
impose two kinds of boundary
conditions.
Say delta X mu have to be 0.
So evaluated at sigma
equal to 0, pi, equal to 0.
Sigma 0 or pi-- it does
not have to be the same.
Or this thing is
0, gamma sigma b.
The reason the sigma here,
because we are interested
only in the boundary term
in the sigma direction.
The boundary term in the
time direction we [INAUDIBLE]
care about.
Because the boundary term
in the time direction,
we always assume in the far
past and the far future,
nothing happens.
We always assume that.
But you cannot assume a boundary
condition at the spatial
condition.
You have-- yeah, in
the spatial boundary,
you have to be
careful, because we
have a finite--
[? a special ?] extension.
OK, so that's why this sigma.
So a lot of the possible
boundary conditions,
gamma sigma b, times partial
b X mu, so evaluated at sigma
is equal to 0 or pi, equal to 0.
So this is normally called the
Dirichlet boundary condition.
This is normally call the
Neumann boundary condition.
The reason this is called
Dirichlet boundary condition
because if that X is
fixed at the end point,
it means that the value of
X are not allowed to vary.
So this is normally
called the Dirichlet, OK?
And for the Neumann
boundary condition,
you only constrain
the derivative.
And the value of
X can be anything.
And you only constrain
the derivative.
So this is called the
Neumann boundary condition.
So for simplicity, later
we will treat both of them.
But for now, let me
just look at this one,
because this one is
slightly simpler.
So for the moment, let me just
consider the Neumann boundary
condition, OK.
So now the second step
is fixing the gauge.
Second step is fixing the gauge.
So we have two gauge freedom.
One is to change
the coordinates.
And the one is to do a scaling.
OK.
So before we fix
the gauge, let's
do a little bit of counting.
So here I can change coordinates
by arbitrary two functions, OK?
So here I essentially have
two arbitrary functions
with freedom of
the gauge freedom.
And here, I have one
arbitrary functions
for both gauge freedom, because
I can choose omega [INAUDIBLE]
arbitrarily.
And if you look at gamma ab,
the worldsheet metric-- so ab
is from 0 to 1.
So this also has three freedoms,
three degrees of freedom.
So that means actually,
in [INAUDIBLE] theory,
at least you can expect
by taking account
those degrees of freedom, taking
account of these three gauge
degrees freedom, you
can set this gamma ab
to some fixed metric.
Because there's only three
freedom here, and we have three
gauge freedom.
And you can completely fix them.
So [? not ?] let
me erase it now.
Now let me do the second step.
Gauge fixing using this
different morphism of b,
so these have two parameters.
You can show that
you can just make
a coordinate transformation.
Take any gamma ab, you
can show that by using
a coordinate transformation,
you can transform the gamma
ab to the following form.
OK.
So I will not prove
it here, but I'll
let you go back to try to
convince yourself of this fact,
OK?
Just by using the
coordinate transformation
starting with
generic gamma ab, you
can make a coordinate
transformation
so that in the new
coordinates, the gamma ab
is given by a prefactor
times the Minkowski metric.
And now we can use
the c, that guy,
because we have the
freedom to change the gamma
ab by arbitrary function.
And then we can just
choose that function
to be [INAUDIBLE] to this guy.
Then we can set gamma
ab just equal to eta ab.
OK.
So we can use these two
freedom to set the gamma
ab with eta ab.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So you're saying
that we can [INAUDIBLE] gauge
[? toward ?] locally
on the worldsheet.
[INAUDIBLE] gauge transform
the metric [? globally ?]
[INAUDIBLE].
HONG LIU: That's right.
Yeah, we can transform it
locally into [? flat ?] metric.
And then, indeed, there
is a global issue of which
I will not worry about now.
Yeah, because the question
which I'm interested in,
say, the spectrum
only [? consists ?]
of the local questions.
For example, if you
do the path integral,
then you don't have to worry
about the global issues.
AUDIENCE: Why?
Why is it that when
you [INAUDIBLE]?
HONG LIU: Yeah, because
you need to integrate
over all possible
configurations.
And you don't want to do the
overcounting, or count mass.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So we don't
have to work this out.
So why does that mean
we don't have to?
HONG LIU: Yeah.
So let me give you an example.
For example, if you do the
genus g surfaces, and then say
let's do Euclidean again.
It's easier.
Do Euclidean.
Indeed, you can locally
transform to eta ab
the actual set of
discrete parameters.
And then you have to be
careful about those discrete
parameters, et cetera.
Yeah, just those
discrete parameters
have to do with global
issues, et cetera.
AUDIENCE: I see
what you're saying.
HONG LIU: Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
HONG LIU: Yeah, just
imagine you have
some two-dimensional surface.
Right now let's not
consider about the topology.
Right now just consider.
So in this case, for the closed
string, the simplest thing--
you can see this
[? sitting ?] there.
So this is sigma direction.
This is the tau direction.
Yeah.
Yeah, for the closed
string it's [INAUDIBLE].
But the open string,
roughly just like this.
And right now we don't
consider complicated topology.
We just consider local question.
Then we can consider
the simplest topology.
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
sorry, I didn't quite
get the path integral being--
HONG LIU: Yeah,
don't worry about it.
AUDIENCE: Don't you
have to integrate around
both sides of every
[? pole that ?] you
have in the--
HONG LIU: Yeah, you have to
integrate over everything.
You have to be careful
about everything.
AUDIENCE: So global
[? effect is a factor. ?]
HONG LIU: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: It does matter.
OK.
HONG LIU: Of course.
AUDIENCE: I thought you
were saying the other.
HONG LIU: No, no, no.
I'm saying the global effects
are very important when
you do the path integral, and
if you want to do the path
integral correctly.
But here we are interested
in the spectrum.
And this is a local question.
OK, so now with
this gauge fixing,
we can see how the equation
of motion simplifies.
First we have fixed
all gauge freedom, OK?
So let's look at the six first.
So six just become a
free scalar equation.
Because when gamma ab
become a Minkowski metric,
this is just like
a scalar field, OK?
This is like a scalar field.
So this we can write explicitly.
So this is a free scalar field.
And let me call this
somehow-- oh, yeah,
let me call this seven.
This one seven,
this one eight, just
to be consistent with my notes.
Then I call this nine.
But if we still have to
worry about the five,
OK, so the five can now
also be written explicitly.
So first thing you can check
is that T0,0 is equal to T1,1,
so the diagonal
elements are the same.
It's given by 1/2 partial
tau X mu partial tau
X mu, plus partial sigma X mu
partial sigma X mu equal to 0.
And T0,1 component will give
you partial tau X mu [? times ?]
partial sigma X mu equal to 0.
So I'm just writing
everything explicitly.
So these are the
three components
of that equation, when I set
gamma ab equal to eta ab.
You can easily check yourself.
Just plug that in.
OK?
So the reason that T0,0 is equal
to T1,1 is because we actually
have a scaling symmetry.
So in the case when
this action-- yeah,
this is a free
massless scalar field.
It's a scaling symmetry.
And you know that when you
have a scaling symmetry under
the stress tensor, the
[? trace ?] of the stress
tensor always vanishes, so
that's why T0,0 and T1,1.
So for the open
string, we also have
to worry about the
boundary conditions.
And so this just become
the Minkowski metric.
And the sigma sigma, only
the sigma sigma is non-zero.
So you just get the partial
sigma X mu equal to 0.
OK, so this should be evaluated
at sigma equal to 0 and pi.
So right now, we only consider
Neumann boundary condition.
And let me call it 12.
So this is for Neumann.
Good?
Any questions on this?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: For this Dirichlet
boundary condition,
it's a [? valuation. ?]
So you already may say
the [? valuation ?] is
arbitrary by [INAUDIBLE] can be
arbitrary.
So it seems like only Neumann
boundary condition is valid.
HONG LIU: Yeah,
this is your choice.
This is your choice.
So normally in the field
theory, what we do-- indeed,
normally in the field theory,
yeah, this is your choice.
In the normal field theory,
where you consider, say,
an infinite space, we
just assume everything
goes to 0 at infinity.
And we don't even need to worry
about the boundary condition.
Then the boundary term
automatically vanishes.
And so that's why,
normally, in the field
theory in the infinite
space, we never
worry about the
boundary conditions
because we made that assumption.
So here, because the string
has a finite [? lens, ?]
it's a finite boundary.
And then you actually have
a freedom to introduce both.
Yeah.
You do have the freedom
to introduce both.
Good?
So let me emphasize again.
So now in this gauge, we just
have a free scalar field.
So this is a standard
wave equation in one
plus one dimension.
But we are not quantizing
a free scalar field theory,
because we still have
to solve those things.
We have to solve
these two equations.
And these are constraints.
Because in this
equation, in principle,
you completely
solve the equation.
We know that this
is a wave equation.
You already solved X completely.
But these two equation,
coming from the gamma equation
of motion, they impose
a [? longitudinal ?]
constraint we have to satisfy.
And those constraints
actually last [INAUDIBLE]
because they are non-linear.
This is a linear
equation, but these
are non-linear constraints.
And this is the 10,
11-- I'll normally
call them Virasoro constraints.
Virasoro was a person.
So this is the
Virasoro constraints.
OK?
And so this allows
me to constrain
the equation [INAUDIBLE].
So now let's first
solve the easy equation.
So let's go to the third
step, trying to solve
the equation of motion.
And now we have fixed the gauge.
And now we try to solve
the equation of motion, OK?
So for people at your
level, I can write down
a solution of line immediately.
So I can have a constant, of
course, satisfy this equation.
I can have a linear term in
tau, which of course will
satisfy this equation.
For closed string,
in principle, I
can also have a
linear term in sigma,
but that won't satisfy the
periodic boundary condition.
So that's not allowed.
And then I can add the
traveling wave solutions.
So this is a left-moving
wave, a right-moving wave,
and this is a left-moving wave.
OK?
So this is a full set
of solutions to-- so
x mu are arbitrary constants.
x mu and v mu are
arbitrary constants.
And XL and XR are arbitrary
for closed strings.
So XL and XR just
are independent,
should be independent periodic
functions of period 2 pi.
OK?
Because they have to be.
So XL and XR are function
of single variable.
And they have to be
period in sigma means
they have to be periodic.
So these are the
periodic function.
OK, is this clear to you?
Do I need to explain
this equation?
Good.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Why a function
of tau minus the sigma?
HONG LIU: It's because
you have a traveling wave.
Because first we can
immediately see this
satisfies this equation.
And then you need
to convince yourself
these are the only solutions,
in the sense that-- yeah,
because these are the
two arbitrary functions.
There's no other
choices anymore.
Any more questions on this?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
HONG LIU: Also not,
for other reasons.
Not for the Neumann
boundary condition.
Not for this
boundary connection.
And now we are come
to open string.
So for open string, you can
then be-- again, we have these.
We can check that if
you have a linear sigma
term [? it will be ?]
incompatible with this boundary
condition, so we don't
worry about that.
So we don't worry about that.
And then, from this
equation, then plug that
into this equation, we
conclude that the XL prime tau
should be equal to XR prime
tau at sigma equal to 0.
And XL prime, tau
minus pi, should
be equal to XR prime, tau
plus pi, at sigma equal to pi.
OK, so you just
plug this into here.
So the first two
terms does not matter,
and then you just have
the last two terms.
So the last two terms,
then if you evaluate it
at sigma equal to 0, then you
just get this equal to that.
And if you evaluate it
at sigma equal to pi,
then find this, OK?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Why is
it that you don't
package those original
two terms into the right
and left functions?
So why is that you write
x mu plus v mu tau?
HONG LIU: Because those
equation don't have this form.
They're not in the form of tau
plus sigma or tau minus sigma.
No, this is just tau.
This is not tau plus sigma.
Now, I can [? pack it ?]
in that form.
It doesn't matter.
I'm just saying here
I'm not doing this.
Yeah.
What I'm saying-- these are
trivially periodic functions.
And yeah, I
[? just separate ?] that.
OK?
So now, from here, you can
find that-- so this equation
tells you that XL is
essentially equal to XR, OK?
So up to a constant we can
absorb into X mu, for example.
Then these two functions
could be the same.
And if we take these two
function to be the same,
then this function
tells us this is
a function-- the
second line tells
us this is periodic in 2 pi.
OK?
Yeah, I actually think I
missed a minus sign here.
So if I take the
sigma derivative,
yeah, I can put a
minus sign here.
But these two conclusions
still are right.
So now for both open
and closed string,
you have solved nine completely.
Solved nine completely.
Any questions about this?
OK, but we still have
to solve 10 and 11.
So what 10 and 11
does is to impose
some nontrivial constraints
between XL and XR
and x mu and v, et cetera.
I'd just say plug in this
most general solution
into 10 and 11.
And we'll impose some
constraints on those functions.
So I urge you to try it
a little bit yourself.
And those equations
are not nice equations.
There are lots of nice people.
Yeah, there are lots
of nice equations.
And so at this stage,
we face a decision.
So when you see this 10
and 11 are hard to solve,
then you have a
decision to make.
Yeah, whenever
you have something
that you don't know
how to do immediately,
you have a decision to make.
We have some decision to make.
Or you just give up.
And first-- so one option
is that we could just
quantize this theory.
We know how to quantize this
free scalar field theory.
We just quantized this free
scalar field theory first.
And then we can construct
the Hilbert space, et cetera.
And then we can impose
those constraints
at the quantum level.
We can impose those constraints
Yeah, so this is one option.
The second option is that
you find some ingenious way
to solve those equations
so that you can actually
find independent variables.
OK, because those are
constraint equations,
means some degrees of freedom
allow the independence
from others.
So the alternative is, I
guess, you just solve it.
And finally, independently, with
freedom, and then quantize only
[? those ?] independently
with freedom.
OK.
So the first option,
this stage is easy,
because you can quantize the
first [? gauge ?] field theory.
But the process will impose the
constraint at a quantum level.
It's actually rather tricky.
So I will not go there.
So I will do the second
method, [? rather ?]
we try to solve this
constraint, find some trick
to solve this constraint,
and then quantize
independent degrees freedom.
Is it clear?
So I will take the
second approach.
So this is the idea of the
light-cone quantization, OK?
So this is the idea of going
to the light-cone gauge.
So this is an ingenious way
to solve those constraints.
OK?
And it was first
developed by four people,
including our colleague here,
Goldstone, Jeffrey Goldstone,
who was among the first people
to quantize this theory,
using the light-cone gauge.
Actually they quantized
the Nambu-Goto action.
They did not
quantize this theory.
They quantized the
Nambu-Goto action
using the light-cone gauge.
So the key idea
is the following.
He said after fixing this
gauge, after fixing gamma ab,
you go to eta ab.
There are actually still
some residue gauge freedom.
We actually have not
fixed everything.
OK.
By residue gauge
degrees freedom--
so if you fix the
gauge completely,
then that means that any
operation which previously--
what we did b and c--
when you act on gamma,
we will take this away from
this configuration, OK?
So by residue
degrees freedom, it
means I can still
find the combination
of coordinate transformation
and the Weyl scaling
so that after those
operations, I'm still
going back to this metric.
OK, so is it clear what we mean
by the residue gauge freedom?
Good.
So to see this I
have to introduce
so-called the light-cone
coordinate on the worldsheet,
introduce sigma plus/minus equal
to square root 2 tau plus/minus
sigma.
And then the
worldsheet metric can
be written as minus d
tau square plus d sigma
square-- because we take
the Minkowski metric.
So this can be written as minus
2 d sigma plus, d sigma minus.
So now here is the
key observation
is that this metric is preserved
by the following coordinate
transformation.
I take sigma plus goes to
sigma tilde plus, which is only
a function of sigma plus.
And sigma minus goes to some
function sigma tilde minus,
some new coordinate sigma
tilde minus, which is only
a function of sigma minus.
So if you've plugged
this in here,
then you'll find under this
coordinate transformation,
we get this ds tilde square.
If you just plug this
in here, this is,
say, 2d sigma tilde plus,
2 sigma tilde minus.
You go to new coordinates.
And [? these ?] new
coordinates expressed
in terms of original
coordinates,
you get 2f prime sigma
plus, g prime sigma minus,
and d sigma d minus.
So now the key is that under
this coordinate transformation,
you only transform your metric
by an overall prefactor.
And then you can get rid
[? of it ?] by Weyl scaling.
It is preserved by this,
followed by Weyl scaling.
Because this coordinate
transformation only
changed your metric by
an overall prefactor.
And any overall prefactor you
can get rid of by Weyl scaling.
OK, is this clear?
So we actually still have some
residue of gauge freedom left.
OK?
So now we can use this freedom
to do something good for us.
So these new coordinates, say,
in this new tilde coordinate,
tau tilde, then have the form
of square root sigma plus tilde
plus sigma tilde minus.
OK.
So this have the form 1
over 2 f sigma plus tau,
and g sigma minus tau,
say tau minus sigma.
So I have this form.
So in this new
coordinate, yes, so you
can change the coordinates.
So you're allowed to make this
kind of coordinate change.
So you are allowed to make
this kind of coordinate change.
Yes, so the residue
degrees freedom
means we are allowed to make
this kind of coordinate change,
OK?
And that means--
and you see, this
is precisely the combination of
this form, a left-moving wave
plus a right-moving wave.
So that means we can
use this freedom.
We can choose.
So this means we
can choose f and g
so that tau is given by any
combinations of this X--
the solutions of X, OK?
Because solutions of X
precisely have this form.
So what we will do is we will--
maybe should I erase this?
Yeah, let me erase this because
I think you all know this.
So I did a level of
the equation of motion.
You have the freedom.
[? You're going to ?] choose
tau tilde to be any
combinations of those X, OK?
Because those X precisely
have that freedom.
And the smart choice is what
we call the light-cone gauge--
we can choose so that tau tilde
is proportional to so-called X
plus.
And X plus is defined
by square root of 2,
say, the 0-th component
of X plus, say,
one of the spatial directions.
OK, say, take one.
So to fix this gauge, to fix to
fix this residue gauge freedom,
I have the freedom
to choose tau tilde
to be some combination of X.
And this is the combination
that we will choose.
So this is what we call
the light-cone gauge.
So I will suppress this tilde.
So in the light-cone gauge
means we go to a coordinate
so that tau become equal to X
plus, and up to some constant
which I called V plus.
OK.
So V plus is some constant.
Is this clear to you?
And this is so-called light-cone
coordinate in the target space.
So this [INAUDIBLE] identify
the worldsheet's time
with the light-cone time
in the target space.
Or in other words, X plus
equal to V plus, tau.
This is what we call
light-cone gauge.
So why do we want to do that?
And the ingenious
thing is the following.
It's that if you
write X mu, so we
can write X mu as X
plus, X minus, and Xi.
And the i come from
2 to D minus 1.
So X plus and X
minus is X0 and X1.
So that's right in this form.
OK, then you can
easily check yourself,
or you maybe already
know it, is that
this particular contraction
is given by 2X plus, X minus,
plus Xi squared.
In particular [INAUDIBLE],
just as here, which you have
this off-diagonal structure.
This kind of contraction has
this off-diagonal structure
in X plus and X minus.
And this turns out to be key.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Do you mean
for that to be 0 and 1,
and then that to be plus 1?
HONG LIU: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: Do you mean
for that to be 0 and 1?
HONG LIU: So these two are
equivalent to X0 and X1.
Let me include
the rest, starting
from i equal to 2 to D minus 1.
So X mu have X0, X1, then
what I would call Xi, which
i start from 2 to D minus 1.
I just renamed these two
to be X plus and X minus.
Just change this two
to X plus and X minus.
AUDIENCE: Oh, I see.
OK.
HONG LIU: Yes?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So when
we do another one,
[? I thought ?]
the Weyl scaling's
already fixed when you're
trying to fix [INAUDIBLE].
HONG LIU: No, no.
I'm just saying I do these two
operation, but in sequence.
So I do that operation, and
then I choose the Weyl scaling
so that precisely cancels this.
Of course, if you just
do a single Weyl scaling,
this will be violated.
But if I do that two
operation together,
then this will be preserved.
Yeah, I have to do
that two together.
Yeah, if you do a single one,
this will be invalidated.
OK, so this is the key point.
So we will see that this
structure will play a key role.
So this is the smart thing
which our friend Jeffrey did.
This is in fact the ingenious
thing of our friend Jeffrey
and his friends [? did. ?]
So now let's look at
these two equations, OK?
Now let's look at
these two equations.
So the first thing-- so now
let's look at 10 plus 11.
So first let's note, because
of this, partial tau X
plus is equal to V plus,
and partial sigma X
plus is equal to 0.
OK?
Because there's no
sigma dependence there,
only tau dependence,
which isn't in here.
And then let me just plug it in.
So let's look at here.
Let's forget about the 1/2.
You can also think about
the 1/2, doesn't matter.
So look at plus and
minus structure here.
Use this here.
Then you get minus 2 V plus,
partial tau X minus, then
plus partial tau Xi squared.
This is for the first term.
In the second term, the X
plus and the X minus part
is 0 because of these.
Because of this and because
of the off-diagonal structure
here, OK?
Do you see it?
So the first term here would
be partial tau minus 2,
partial sigma X
plus, partial sigma X
minus plus partial
sigma Xi squared.
So this would be 0.
But our friend here is
0, because of that is 0.
So now we can erase it.
So now let's change
this to the other side.
OK.
Let's change this
to the other side,
and then change this sign.
So the equation I
get is the following.
OK, so this is equation 10.
So now let's look
at equation 11.
In 11, so we have
partial tau X plus,
then partial sigma X minus.
Then you go to partial tau
Xi and partial sigma Xi.
And then this one
just give us V plus.
So that two equation
become these two equation.
And let me call this 14.
This is 15.
So is it clear to
you, these equations?
So if it's not immediately clear
to you, just check it yourself.
OK.
Urge you to do the
check, because then you
will see the magic.
Then you will see the magic
and the beauty of this trick.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
HONG LIU: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: Can you tell X minus
[INAUDIBLE] sigma X plus?
HONG LIU: Yeah, that's 0
because partial 0 X plus is 0.
So that's why there's
only one here, not two.
Because the other term is 0.
OK, so now the beauty
of these two equation
is that they express the X
minus solely in terms of Xi.
So 14 and 15 tells you, is that
X minus can be fully solved
in terms of Xi.
Because this equation give you
the tau derivative of X minus,
this equation give you the
sigma derivative of X minus,
and all expressed
only in terms of Xi.
So the X minus is completely
solved, completely expressed,
in terms of Xi.
And then we have solved those
constraints [? similarly ?]
[INAUDIBLE] constraint
explicitly, OK?
So right now we are doing
it a little bit fast.
I urge you to go through the
algebra yourself to appreciate
the beauty of this step.
So we conclude that independent
degrees freedoms are only Xi.
Because X plus we already
know by fixing the gauge.
And X minus now is completely
solving in terms of Xi,
so the independent
freedom are only Xi's.
And this will make
our life very easy.
Because Xi are just
free scalar fields.
Xi-- just free scalar field
with the right kinetic term.
You have also get rid of
X0, because we said that
[? before ?] X0, we have a
[? long-sign ?] kinetic term.
But now we are only
independent-- [INAUDIBLE]
only Xi's, and they have the
right number of kinetic terms.
They have the right sign
for the kinetic term.
And they are just
free scalar fields.
So we can quantize
them as what you
did in your first day of
Quantum Field Theory class.
And then you have quantized
the string theory.
And then you have
quantized string theory.
OK, yeah.
I think I'm going
very slow here.
Maybe I'm a little
bit too emotional.
Anyway, so maybe
let's stop here.
The next time, then we will
just quantize those things.
And those equations
still will give us
some very important
information, and then we
will quantize those things.
And then we will be able to see
that the string theory contains
gravity.
It contains gravitons, OK?